um we both have very young kids yours
are two are two and six right that's
right okay are your kids musical they
are yeah um they are I think they're
more talented than I ever was at their
ages you know you sound like a
parent they're they no they're exposed
to it so more so much more than I was
they're so much more comfortable than I
was you know yeah they're they really
how about yours are yours I the say you
know now that you say that I think
because they grow up around it right so
they don't know any different so they've
always seen me mommy on stage always
come on stage when they're baby so like
I I think that they don't it kind of
shakes off the nerves a bit for them
yeah your voice is so magical I was
listening to you earlier oh it's so good
so what what was like your favorite song
as a kid what's like what did you grow
up oh you know I remember the first
grown-up song I think we share this one
the first the first grown-up song that I
really liked was Greatest Love of All
whitne Me did you did you put it on her
Pete in your room and just keep belting
it out I did yeah yeah that's me yeah
and my mom hat hated it like it's paying
off now but it was a lot of we lived in
a very small
duplex yeah I don't think my neighbors
liked it either but it's like her songs
were so fun especially that one and the
message it makes you cry what a message
I uh yeah I remember there's this
there's this cassette tape that I have
from when I was a kid uh I had my own
tape record in my room and I'm just
doing that last uh you know I'm just
looping that the final chorus
you Prodigy no Prodigy and and you're in
your head you are Whitney you were like
I am killing this yes oh my God and they
had to listen to
it I love I love that did you ever do
the um because we're the same around the
same age did you ever do the like play
and record to where you could record on
your like that was with my first demo I
did like the you could kind of mess with
the tape on it and then you could record
yourself on your so I recorded over
people I was like I don't like this
anymore oh yeah I would do I would do my
own background vocals you know what I
mean I was not that cool oh yeah cuz you
could like if you record it on this side
you then you put it on this side then oh
the dou yes yeah and then You' keep
flipping the double for a minute yeah
that cost more I was like yeah that was
that's really cool you're were Rich um
[Music]
[Applause]
so thank you guys have a great night I'm
going
home